I wanted to watch this um this is sunny
fast I don't know if you heard about it
he reacts to videos with his mom okay
but he did a street interview in Boston
oh I've seen him yeah he's he's dope
he's in my course the creativity kit uh
dropping February 1st and he's you know
he's exposing the Bots by asking them
what they think about NG tape what's up
YouTube as you guys all know Andrew Tate
just got arrested The Matrix is
attacking closing in on their face too
so here we're out in Boston spaniel Hall
asking people what are their thoughts on
Andrew take getting life in prison so
what are your thoughts on Andrew Tate
getting life in prison for sex
trafficking awesome awesome sauce you
saw that right no what oh Muslims on
someone went to jail like
they're so ugly
why see this is what it is Pearl about
everybody like they're just the inverse
of these people the people that hate the
truth are just coping that they their
failures they're ugly they it's always
the same thing like people who are
successful rich or good looking or in
shape they don't hate the truth
so you think he deserves life in prison
for what he's done yeah what are your
overall thoughts on Andrew Tate do you
like him or not I know
what the girl even know you literally
don't even know them and that's the the
thing I always get from women and you
know and some blue pill
you guys chat will know who I'm talking
about some beta blue pills church people
I'm not gonna say names but it's like
they'll be like oh the red pill is just
angry men
and I'm just like
I'm I'm just like
it's not even about that it's about
discovering truth you know what I mean
exactly Pro you are awesome my wife
loves watching you thanks for showing
the world that the red pill is the true
pill there you go snico didn't mean to
make you feel bad with the boxing
comment God bless that he said earlier
and I don't know that he could beat me
up
don't you like him he's a bad person why
because he's a bad person he's bought
some bad things he's not a good person
what has he done that you personally
don't like on the right
um a baby hippo a baby a little baby
hippo you know yeah I don't see the
hippo territory yet like a beluga whale
not a not a not a great white whale
what's the big whale not a sperm whale
just a I don't know I should know the
name you got to learn the term there's
uh I don't know the whale name the blue
whale that's the biggest one not a blue
she's a beluga okay okay
like you know the bad stuff
stick and such being much harder
understood how like what do you think
can make someone misogynistic like what
did he say that um makes you think that
don't remember exactly but he got bought
famous for being like misogynistic yeah
do you remember anything he said
specifically nope so I'm sure you guys
have heard of him but what are your
thoughts on Andrew Tate
what do you think they are
I want to guess what do you think
they're gonna say have you seen this
before I haven't seen it I haven't seen
it there's one more I've been a fan for
a long time watching extremes season one
I I feel like the girl on the left is
gonna hate him and she won't have an
opinion what do you think
um well they're attractive so I well I
don't know how it should actually take
that back I don't know how old they are
but I think they're gonna be less
angry then well we'll see it's it's
recent
I want to get this right
um
I think the one with their titties out
is going to be more positive and she's
gonna be like I don't really know
they're not gonna be as bad as the first
two okay
all right I'm sure you love them are you
so for real are we for real I'm being
for real why don't you like them do you
like him depends depends do you like him
oh so you like him if I like him you
hate him if I hate him I don't know no I
have I have my stances what are your
thoughts so why do you like them I don't
like them because human trafficker all
right yeah you got it you got it we'll
see I don't know if she hasn't given her
opinion on the right yet misogynist I
feel like that's yeah I've seen that a
good amount I thought so because she
looked kind of [ __ ] so that's why I
thought she was but she looks like a
wholesome girl so I was like oh she's
got the she got a cross on her neck yeah
that sounds like girl on the right very
receptive you have unmatched uh
perspicacity from the news titles what
about you yeah I don't know enough about
him nice that's fair that's so what has
he said specifically that you don't like
him for I feel like
um I don't really have to like listen to
all of his videos and like do all of
that to listen to them specifically but
reading this is stupid hey that's really
you're just how do people not hear how
dumb they are when they speak I haven't
watched anything I don't feel like I
have to I just don't like him and I
don't know why
strong ass opinion
paints like you
getting all the articles that I've read
that works for me have you ever thought
some article titles or Clips take like
you know Clips cut up could be taken out
of context or for the most part it's the
way it is for the most part and based
off the people that like him that also
says a lot too what if I liked him would
that that sucks for you and I really
hope that maybe you don't yeah good
thing I hate him he's a he's a
misogynist I talked to him before and he
was he was misogynistic to me
at least the Jesus girl knows that uh
isn't that crazy
yeah
yeah it's wild but he has you just saw
him he got life in prison for sex
trafficking I'm sure you've seen that
all over social media I didn't realize
he actually went to prison for it yeah
it's crazy it's just it's like 20 over
the last 24 hours it's really new
I'm not lying to you you can look it up
right now
I pinky promise
maybe I lied
[Music]
all right well thank you guys so much
for your time here do you have like a
Snapchat or anything
can I get it
what the hell
no oh man is it because I like tape
well thank you guys
why did the Jesus go for a Snapchat she
doesn't feel you bro Sonny took it out
on the camera really you tell him to
handicap well yesterday that she has no
boundaries what's stopping you LMAO
whales only have handicaps to fall back
on keep fighting the good fight against
these sea cows sea cows yeah that's a
good one for the Arsenal good one t
you're [ __ ] selling me man what the
hell what's your name October oh well
okay yeah like she just you know
everything she's gonna say this is what
I mean when I say Bots what the [ __ ] you
think she thinks
October I'm Sunny nice to meet you so
what are your thoughts on Andrew Tate
getting life in prison I think
sjw's raider one to ten
bro almost a boy it looks like pretty
much looks like it belongs on the
storyboard collage like if you just are
you trans
liberalism is a disease it's it's that's
the real pandemic that's the real virus
it infects people and makes you worse
like she even has the note the witch
nose piercing this demonic and it's like
um I tried it my you know my youngest
sister is a liberal
how do I how do I save her call her
robot yeah like men should be in touch
with their masculinity and stuff like
that
not a fan of sexist and doesn't he
promote all the [ __ ] about like
oh women shouldn't do this and men
should be powerful and all this [ __ ]
yeah like men should be in touch with
their masculinity and stuff like that
not a fan
men shouldn't be in touch with their
masculinity masculinity is bad according
to the woke people but as he said that
you don't specifically like I don't know
or like that sexist I don't generally
keep up with him a lot but I know that
didn't he create like a men's club or
whatever trying to promote like oh men
are better and we should wear the
superior sex and all that jazz no he
didn't well no he has like his um
organizations and stuff but it's not
just like men are better all right well
thank you for your time it was good
meeting you October you could have done
way better with her I should have
introduced with my pronouns
do you like him or no hard pass
hard pass why not why don't you like
them I don't appreciate his views it's
kind of the same dynamic
too it's like the sweet friend and the
one of the rights of sweet friend I
think the left is a [ __ ] yeah three or
four she's got the the die do you always
know it's dyed redheads
yeah fake redheads yeah I'm a real
Ginger you actually burn in the sun yeah
but it's like they want to be you so bad
it
red hair looks so bad to me it just
looks fake I didn't even notice that
this is like some gender [ __ ]
or just his concept of reality yeah what
has he said about women that you don't
like he's just made really objectifying
and negative comments about women like
anything specific
um I don't have his quotes for baby none
of them do not one NPC they looked the
front on the right it's like oh she's
kind of some don't meet him but I just
recall different interviews where he's
just basically said that women are
objects that men possess and so that's a
hard pass for me what are your thoughts
on Andrew Tate getting life in prison
I'm sure you've seen it all over social
media I actually don't oh it's all good
then so what are your thoughts on Andrew
Tate you like him or passer
why don't you like them just like
how he perceives himself to the internet
how he perceives himself
how he perceives himself to the internet
what
kind of nothing
try to sound this happens on the show
all the time it's like you'll ask a
question and they'll literally say
nothing straight up boss like actually
this is what red pills a lot of people I
started out kind of a bot too doing like
it's in the Matrix if you want to be red
pilled do Street interviews and talk to
the average person and then you probably
have the same diagnosis most people have
nothing to say like the average person
has absolutely no original opinions
about anything they don't think past
level two they just go like to the mall
eat food
do their job and then they you ask them
about and they have nothing
that's most of the population it's
really insane and this happened to me
from interviewing it just happened to
you it's happening it's a great way to
learn about the world have you ever been
attacked interviewing never no never
never that was just a new thing oh
you've been attacked I told you I
thought I told you the whale attack oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah just once just once
yeah well I don't yeah I know better
than sir
I want to go and do Street interviews
and ask fat chicks why they're fat
why are you fat one of my favorite ones
uh was is it okay to be fat
I think that's a great video um
I think it captured uh like it says at
the time and people didn't even have any
any reason oh that's the whale attack
don't say it's normal
it was what that they had to blur it to
get it on you oh she she put a privacy
Point where's the whales out here no uh
yeah I go to the beginning there roughly
oh it's in the beginning no no no I'm
saying where you were yeah I think
roughly there
no
no because people don't wear them
t-shirts saying is she crying
no she was just very
I don't know I'm not gonna rape you and
the chances are the last to say I'm not
gonna rape you are the [ __ ] ones that
will
so
I need you to I need you to stop you're
being very no man no no no no and this
is
Jesse Jesse you had one job keep this
[ __ ] from me why would you let her buy
me again bro this dude was your
bodyguard yeah he because she tried to
like come at me before and then he
pulled her back and then he let her buy
me again why would you do that you had
one job he wasn't a bodyguard he was
like another interviewer but that was
like he's like a smaller like that was
the only reason I brought him was to
protect me was because I didn't want to
get hit by the whale call him a sword
boy is he a sore boy no no
what's that wait what's a soy boy oh the
people in these pictures
okay this day this day is absolutely a
soy boy you better find me but because
it's not mad you really
because you guys are acting crazy you're
acting crazy
let's massage
let's massage
walking home alone at night if you're in
a big city like I wouldn't I just
wouldn't walk home alone at night
foreign
the tolerant left chat
see it's like holding her back from the
mic cut
yeah that blurring was not that good I
could completely see both their faces
what's up
you didn't even say that bad no I know
you look like a whale I know and she
said
my Tick Tock account I almost had a
million followers taken down this clip
because I put in the subtitle so they
could see what I said
a million a million followers almost RP
I also mine too yeah it's just yeah but
it's like it wasn't even that bad no no
do you look you look like that's it
your little [ __ ] oh
hi guys
so this is
a relaxed brother
woke is a real disease
I love students I love smoothies but
great job at staying uh composed to the
situation
I'm pretty sure
good job I expect most I think most
women would get uh emotional in that
situation and try to fight that wasn't
bad at all we said yo Pearl astronaut
will probably go like this other someone
like a video let's go back to this
confident or isn't confident confident
who's strong or weak
[Music]
tall or short it's all that can fight or
can't fight
horribly seems like you guys like tape
nice personality
so what has he said that you guys don't
like there was like there was
there was how he would like smack a girl
I know this might be crazy what if I
told you that clip was taken out of
context
do you think that there's a possibility
that a lot of the stuff he's getting
canceled for is just taken out of
context to cancel him or do you think
it's it's truly deserved wait why did he
get
like that was just a joke
oh I said do you think it's possible
that a lot of the stuff he's getting
canceled for is just taken out of
context and that is just really an
agenda to get people to not like him or
do you think all the allegations are
true
it could go yeah it could go
I think you trust the media fully or no
do you like to say your critical
thinkers
you know you're full of [ __ ] yeah no you
were talking about good I don't even
know what to say man these people are
critical thinkers but they believe
everything that the News tells them it's
it's kind of sad everyone said he's
misogynist he's misogynist and they
haven't said one reason why like how do
you all have views and you don't even
know why like that is a problem what are
you guys thoughts on Andrew Tate have
you heard of them they like
yes you like the guy or no haven't heard
of it in a while I feel like there's
multiple viewpoints on him you know you
see the good parts you see the bad parts
overall kind of neutral this is what
your brothers look like
only guy what do you think
um I think that had I seen him and also
a flight of stairs he might find himself
very well accompanied with that okay wow
camera that you want to assault assault
somebody that's the tolerant left that's
wokeness that's people who think toxic
masculinity is bad and they think that
toxically mass people are violent but if
you said that about Megan I'm a stallion
said like if I ever saw her I'd push
down a flight of stairs yeah
you get deleted like you would get
canceled but these people like it it's
fine it's fine to say this about
anti-work people
oh man why don't you like them
um I think it's got something to do with
him balding I don't know I don't like it
okay and another stupid take because the
left will also say that by like we need
to end body shaming and if you called
one of her fat friends of whales she
would get triggered but look how they
weaponize body shaming when it's a small
deck yes yeah it's the same to Greta
Thunderbird how stupid that is like they
all chat change
change right you can't once you lose
your hair like you lost your hair it's
just this [ __ ] is [ __ ] balding so if
I went bald you wouldn't like me
she's not funny just a bad person
oh my God so why don't you like him so
bad like what has he said that you you
disagree with so much no I just I I
don't [ __ ] with people who don't have
hair I don't trust them
hair doesn't like you I simply I can't I
can't support you're right this is crazy
what if I told you that he can grow hair
but he shaves it would that change
things and he's a willingly being gross
you know one thing it's like a genetic
problem like you can't really help it
and then others you choose to live that
way interesting interesting all right
maybe I'll shave my head then so have
you guys heard of Andrew Tate yeah wait
okay
let's see are you predicting predict the
Bots Pro you do you're like five for
five right now
I feel like right girl is not gonna be
about
no she has she has a nose piercing look
look closer oh she got the wish she got
the woke nose piercing come on your
sister has this you already know what's
up they both don't like him
yeah yeah scarf is very you saved me on
this one yeah yeah you gotta she's just
kind of cute though so she's a little
bit attractive for a bot you know yeah
like they're usually uglier than her
what are your thoughts on them he's a
misogynist oh he's killing it man which
knows you know what they think it's it's
so simple the island it's it's this is
why I talk about appearance so much you
could really deduce what someone thinks
completely by the way they look what
happened so why don't you like it
because he's pushing the wrong message
to very susceptible to yours the
teenagers stuff like that see the scarf
and the coffee she's very liberal she
hates Trump you know she talks about oh
but she she's intellectual about her
wokeness like like what message
but
he has said things about women that are
just not okay like I don't know the
exact context but I was reading about it
I said something about how like you can
like I don't know if it was hit woman or
like tell them that
I don't remember the context I'm like
going enough it's good it's good to talk
about do you think it's a problem to
have like strong opinions on something
if you don't have the full context and
see stuff for what it was truly meant I
do but it's not that I don't have it I
just don't remember it off the top of my
head like I have read about it I feel
like something important in this
particular situation with this is that
it's not just one situation it's a
general context of the messages that he
a general context of the messages like
they say this and they don't realize how
they are programmed they know that he's
bad and they have nothing to say no
reason why
in real time they're saying I am
programmed and they still they're
showing themselves malfunction they
don't see it I
crazy because it's always
I think they are because they donate to
Ukraine
but or like they protest climate change
that's how they feel good we we give
them a bunch of reasons to make them
feel good about themselves like
if they if they put their gender
pronouns on their bio if they go cancel
other people they feel good about
themselves were you ever were you ever
Pro BLM
I went to some protests but it was I was
in New York at the time and it was
during quarantine I just want to go
outside like it was a good week because
that's when all the Bots went back
outside I wasn't
maybe a little a little bit they they
get you they had some good marketing no
but it was it was mostly fun like I was
just bored of sitting inside all the all
day
the marketing was was yeah I mean they
got a lot of people there's so many
black squares I never donated money they
brainwashed like an entire generation
basically what if I told you I posted
the black Square
did you for like two hours and I deleted
it but I'm like what am I doing but yeah
it was there wow it was a chat call me a
bot I didn't post the black square but I
think I did my my woke friend was
pissing me off and because she was like
like mad at me for not posting a black
spot this is the same girl that stopped
being friends with me later so but she
um
your preschool friend yeah my preschool
friend she was like pissing me off that
day and she was like because she kept
she sent me this long-ass text being
like I just need to know your stance on
black lives matter like why didn't you
post the black swear and this girl I'm
like you don't even do anything all that
like what is your I have a job and
anyways she um
oh my gosh she basically I donated to
George Floyd's like family because I
just wanted to be like you didn't yeah
oh you're a body I didn't donate money
honestly no but it was it was directly
to the family it wasn't a BLM or maybe
that was the BLM but the reason I did
that was because she was pissing me off
and I was like look I donated my money
what the [ __ ] did you do I mean that's
pretty it was like it was like a petty
it was like a petty donation yeah but
that's all it is it's just trying to
show other people how good of a person
you are I wasn't a bot in the sense that
my merchline quality.clothing I was
working with uh two guilty white people
and they wrote this whole like bulletin
board about like we stand which I'm like
bro there's all these graphics and like
where you can donate money and I'm like
what the [ __ ] does George Floyd have to
do with my merch and what if they even
do with the money it went to black Trans
people and nobody got the money if they
you should see Candace Owens documentary
on it the roommates of George Floyd they
haven't received a dime his car is still
at the house no one came to pick it up
nobody paid for the funeral service they
didn't they got no none of the money
La nightmare says how is the BLM protest
like what happened also where's yay the
BLM protests were it was pretty much the
purge like all these stores got looted I
was making videos covering it and then I
even I went to Portland Oregon to cover
the abolish the police movement they
sectioned off the city and like there
were no traffic lights there were
garbage fires everywhere people were
like covered in Mass they were just
fighting the police antifa took over it
literally became like a no government
Zone full of just degenerate people who
were about BLM and it was funny because
it's like 95 white in that place and
they're all like abolishing the police
for one incident of uh of George Ford
dying
it's it's straight up like woke almost
took over the world they I was in New
York and they were looting Gucci stores
like the protests were just to make a
lot of money and everybody from the hood
they came up they got to make I know
people made like 40 000 reselling Gucci
they didn't give a [ __ ] about George
Floyd really yeah like to this day
they're like oh I can't wait for someone
else to die so we can go loot again
whatever question actually what was
happening
yay um
it was
um
pretty surreal at first like just having
conversation with him or like the
weirdest part was I'll be like chilling
at my hotel afterwards and then you get
a phone call and you see like imagine
you see like yays calling and you're
like wait what the is this real actually
after it first happened I had to be like
is am I actually awake because like
that guy is like one of my actual Heroes
changed my mindset a lot about a lot of
things I think he's extremely red pilled
and part of the reason I dropped out of
school to pursue my dreams all that so
it was um it was surreal like to be like
in hearing him say my name like uh we
were having a debate one time and he was
like pushing back about what I said he's
like maybe I should just let snico be
sneako and I'm like Yay just said that
like I was like what the [ __ ] uh it was
pretty surreal yeah one of the smartest
people like definitely create a genius
he's a genius genius I hate him
I had a really good One Minute Podcast
so it got deleted off YouTube asking if
Kanye versus crazy I think if you still
do reactions that's okay I designed
those people to react to him but no he's
definitely
um yeah I think it's on Rumble I posted
it on Vimeo I wasn't on Rumble one and I
made that video but I'm gonna continue
making the One Minute Podcast in 2023
just
yeah
this is as a general thing and but like
what specifically does he say that you
don't agree with or like
honestly it's not true
like
but it's not just trusting me it's
trusting the facts like anyone can call
someone to go to a house and get them
arrested for something but if there's no
proof around it it doesn't make it true
I guess it's I wish it was as simple as
that but if they really want them to go
down for something I'm sure they could
find a way so any other things that you
could think of why you don't like him or
no I honestly don't know a whole lot
about Andrew Tate but it's all good I'm
sure you've just seen Casey's is he
gonna see this video I'm I'm like you
know good friends with him I think this
is a hand message you're gonna give a
hand message she doesn't know enough
about him but she's gonna flip them off
like just straight up NPC imagine hating
someone that you openly admitted you
don't know anything about
it okay wait you know it's crazy I'm
sorry something I know
I know if there's a guy that was
the truth on the podcast right and the
girls were arguing with him and hated
him the whole show they would always try
to [ __ ] him after
I swear to God I sort of I don't know
like I don't know if it's the same or
like other podcasts but they I they
always would be so flirty with the guy
that they hate it and I bet you if he
came like they would do the same thing
yeah that's I've had that similar
experience on uh many after hours on
fresh and fit like they'll be arguing or
saying like oh you got banned blah blah
blah like it'd be all catty and be just
a straight up [ __ ] on the show
after the show the camera's thrown off
it's a it's a different story but that
that's the nature of women
no all right it was great meeting you
guys what are your thoughts on uh Andrew
Tate
um I don't like his haircut he doesn't
have a haircut yeah exactly and also
yeah none of them do especially yeah I
mean look at them they look like Orcs
and Lord of the Rings you sort of just
annoying he's just annoying what do you
guys like him or no no but he has a lot
of money so valid you guys haven't met
in case he might see this
be nicer to women I guess nicer to women
all right anything you want to say I
don't know top G most famous man in the
world nothing I know because I want I
mean I would love like money fly her out
yeah I don't understand
I don't understand why these strong
independent women will always ask me be
asking men for money get a job like
everyone else
that's it I choose to ignore him yeah if
if that makes sense yeah
he's not on your feet or nothing
[Music]
no do you have any thoughts on them
gay
girl on the right not a bar if she talks
no they're all going to be Bots
I'm gonna still stick to this I'm gonna
stick to it there's that there's just
gonna be all NPCs but did you realize
how stupid that was that he just she
just called Andrew take kind of gay like
as an insult but they'll also Champion
gay people be Pro LGBT but the first
insult they use is the same stuff that
they are trying to fight against yeah he
seems gay you think not like a bad way
just like do the video from jumping into
like the tube like the pool
yeah it was kind of sauce
real quick I jumping into a pool is gay
I know a lot of you guys don't know me
for like my business side but before
starting YouTube and everything I've
generated over five million dollars
um women who are married are property so
I don't agree with it and she says uh
would Pearl ever going fresh and fit
uh what you think about the podcast and
the girls that end up on it
what do I think of the girls that end up
on impression fit yeah
um I think it's a good podcast I think
the girls I would love to have a like
they recruit way better than I do I wish
I had good girls left they got a whole
team doing it yeah I wish our girls that
like feisty they do a good job
with that for sure do you want your guy
to like protect and provide for you
she gets into a fight I guess she can
protect herself
well the mothers I've had this have you
had this happen where their moms email
you uh yeah yeah it's just like lady
there's nothing to do parents the NPR
mom's caring you can like see it on her
face right she was so much she was
handing out masks in a park last year
and I want you to delete their pictures
please all right we won't use this on
show me you deleting them oh oh
no no I swear to God I hate it when old
ladies try to tell me what to do I know
because I I've met her like in a
different body but in London no no no no
no they're like let me see it show me
show me like I don't have to do that I
used to be so much more patient like six
months ago
we can't just delete the whole thing but
we we won't use it
don't use it I promise you I need to
know who you are all right I took their
imagery and I don't trust what they took
their imagery
what the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] is you well I
can show you like my YouTube if you want
so I'm sure you guys have heard of them
but what are you where do you live oh
bro
thoughts on Andrew Tate
he's just he's just a little too like
skinny and like to it's like he's too
ner I don't know it's like he's gonna be
a boy it's the same look of the guys on
the right that you had up yeah yeah
that's why he looks like the sword boy
and also he's going to want to seem good
in front of this girl right here I don't
know if that's a sister but yeah yeah
wow he could fit on this collage
foreign
I mean some of some of the stuff he says
is messed up but then then against some
of the other stuff's like okay you rock
with them you rock with them it's it's
like a little iffy what are your
thoughts on them I don't I don't I don't
like him why don't you like him I don't
agree with most of the things he says
like anything specifically or anything
on see the look look at his look
s
talking
what's in love with that dude no
what's up with her look at this oh yeah
he's something he's something he
definitely likes Andrew tape but he's
trying to
I hate Andrew Tate into some [ __ ] and
would you say that we were wrong about
that one
or right
um
okay you said iffy I don't really know I
always just said it's about take
anything on women so like women are the
most beautiful precious creatures I mean
I believe women are the most precious
things on the planet they create life
they should be protected they should
provide it for us that you should
protect for that he uses
it's like disgusting to me but like how
so because you know I think it's my job
to like protect and provide for the
woman that I'm with but like where does
the lion get crossed it's like he was
like making like he was like
characterizing them and saying like like
if they have more than like one body
they're like they're useless do you
think body count matter you never said
that
more than one I don't for sure no
no do you think body count matters no
facts I'm gonna go and find he's like
I'm trying to add to it
am I a good girl with like 100 bodies
I'm sure you guys have heard of them but
what are your thoughts
yeah she looks like an astrology girl
with those necklaces yeah the Rings and
everything she's big into crystals the
one on the left
um basic [ __ ] she goes to Urban
Outfitters and stuff like that she they
both hit him trying to Andrew Tate oh
[ __ ] him yeah
weird pretty spot on yeah I don't know
we've been wrong like what once twice
yeah yeah facts I don't like them either
so why don't you guys like them piece of
[ __ ] yeah
what is he said that's misogynistic that
you guys don't rock with oh my God so
[ __ ] much probably
comes out of his mouth
like like anything that was [ __ ] god
awful no that specific the video yeah
that was messed up anything else
specific that you don't like them for
what
was that about women knowing her place
or something like that oh yeah yeah it's
every single comedy's ever made about
women yeah valid well do you have
Snapchat or anything
yeah here throw that in there all right
well thank you guys for your time all
right have a good one I hate Tate yeah I
don't I totally don't rock with him
either you know who Andrew Tate is yeah
dude I love him would I would you be
shocked if I told you you were the first
pro Tate person out here all today yeah
nobody likes him anymore dude Andrew
Taylor
you got this bro Andrew Tate's the best
bro notice how all of like the bigger
dudes is inspiring the masculine you are
people who look like they have more of
their [ __ ] together tend to like them
and it's the crazy looking [ __ ]
that all hate tea hilarious you can tell
how they look initially I immediately
know if it's a hit piece or some
[ __ ] video or I know if it's a good
video just from what they look like you
heard of the base mother have you heard
of the bass mother I'm sure you guys
have heard of them but what are your
thoughts on Andrew Tate
I don't think he was setting a good
example for for anyone
I think would be a better example to
look up to as a guy Ryan Reynolds what
why what is Ryan Reynolds ever said
about anything I I couldn't tell you one
thing one opinion he has
so that's all I know
it's valid valid so why don't you guys
like basic hot guys
yeah just like basic a matrix agent the
Hollywood
yeah everything in all of Netflix is
propaganda every every single and if you
pay close attention if you watch a
Netflix movie stuff like that if you
watch any movie nowadays there's always
awoke agenda and all that I just watched
a movie called chef and at the end the
winner everybody dies except for a
literal prostitute she saves a day I
just watched the new Knives Out movie
and the bad guys the white dude like
straight white male bad he's like kind
of playing Elon Musk it's a CEO and then
the good people are the the queers you
know what I'm tired of oh my God I have
such strong opinions on this I am so
tired of seeing all these damn female
CEOs in all these movies they don't
exist they don't exist yeah but that
that's the necklace and all the [ __ ]
the freak dudes are you freaking nuts
and she's still wearing like super tight
clothes like making sure her hair is
perfect like it should mass destruction
of cities burning and her her hair is
still perfect and she's got eye shadow
and [ __ ] and her cleavage like why why
does she need cleavage it makes no sense
you know she hold Mega Sally and
twerking with She-Hulk like it's this
whole every single girl superhero movie
is just revenge on men it's not actually
them saving the world it's just like an
angry fat feminist writing this movie to
take down men why do you think feminist
hate and so much
jealousy it's it's uh it's an ego thing
they are they're jealous of male power
because we've told women that uh being
naturally feminine is a bad thing being
pygmies bad and so they they desperately
want to be men and they also crave
validation for men but a lot of
feminists are ugly
um and so they don't want to present
themselves as wives they just think that
men should like them for who they are
and the thing is they have bad
personalities so a lot of it is
self-hatred that they they project onto
the world you know they don't like the
way they are they're fat and so instead
of accepting the fact that they can lose
weight they just say that you're a bad
person you know it's it's all internal
it's a lack of self-responsibility
people don't want to improve themselves
they don't want to get better they want
to lose weight they don't want to make
more money they don't want to become
smarter look into things they just want
to say that the rest of the world is bad
and we tell them that's a good thing so
that we keep people programmed and
stupid
does that make sense or am I like no no
I think you're
think you're hellstream
S I think he's like kind of
anything to thebove everyone okay would
you rather a guy with confidence or
looks down about himself confidence but
not that much okay would you rather a
guy who's stronger weak strong strong
tall or short tall can fight or can't
fight can't fight rich or not rich
it's kind of funny it seems like a lot
of these traits that you're describing
like match with it what do you think
about like you didn't say sexist or not
sex IST bald or not bald not bald oh all
right well maybe that's where the line
draws I don't really care for him don't
care for him what about you seem like a
fan no don't pay attention no why don't
you like them I've heard that he's like
talking bad about girls have you heard
anything specific or you just heard he
said stuff about people
um I heard something about rape is like
voluntary and like they want it no he
didn't say that he
when
where did she get that
what you heard was wrong thank you guys
so much for watching to our surprise
nobody had a good reason as to why they
don't like Tate and obviously drop in
the comments hashtag free Tate likes
good job Sunny fast keep doing this